two was the choice of uh Hikaru as he is
anticipating the opportunity of playing
Rook B3 and Rook takes D3 as soon as he
can and again we do have in our studio
um sitting down with Maurice Ashley
former world champion Bulgaria's number
one player vesselin
topof
thanks as we're just checking out a
couple of variations for black showing
vesselin a possibility for him that he
had not uh quite looked at veling first
of
all yes it was a bad game for you but
what is going on with this kid the way
he's playing is just pretty phenomenal
well I mean
I
uh well uh what can I say I mean he's
just I don't think he made any mistake
somehow in all these six games and he's
really well prepared so and again uh
every game looks like he found find some
new idea and he POS his problem so it
was uh maybe well in this game somehow I
didn't really um evaluate correctly the
position I thought I had a good position
but maybe it was never really through
when when the moment when you played
Queen A5 we were looking at the the the
databases to find precedent and it
looked like this idea of Queen A5 was
somewhat new or was it something you had
prepared cuz he played Rook E2 instantly
just like he just totally expected this
move that's true uh no I more or less of
course I was not 100% sure he was going
to play like this but I thought that
Queen A5 and then like Bishop G5 and
some kind of normal position but
otherwise it's true that it makes no
sense I mean if I don't push my pawns
then Queen A5 no makes no sense you know
but
maybe um okay here this end game right
here you could have could be a little
bit worse of course but probably it was
well I I thought of course it was his
preparation so uh you know the somehow
the idea of all this lines shouldn't be
you know to to go for a slightly worse
ending and it's maybe black has too many
weaknesses and it looks very easy for
white to play so here uh of course now
yeah but okay this is the line that you
shouldn't you don't normally play you
know to night takes on E5 which was a
long variation we we worked at with the
computer help of course in some ways but
Yer did point out this option in
analysis easier to analyze when you're
KN have to play the game I mean it's
also true that it's uh looks like uh all
this was his preparation it's not like
you go Knight E5 or you go the first
move which is C5 or for um I think his
line probably continues here his it's
amazing how his preparation has been
quite powerful later we saw your
position start to stabilize Rook E8 and
then it got to a point around Bishop C3
that it looked like you didn't have much
to do it how how your game you know that
I thought that actually my plan should
be to place my knight on f8 and then
Knight G6 you know and then sudden
sometimes jumping on F4 but it's true
that the Rook on G7 is totally out of of
play so that was the reason I I thought
that I could you know jump with my
knight on D4 and to centralize but it's
simply not working and and of course
here I blended what I did what I missed
was um here of course my original
intention was to go King G7 ah but then
uh Queen E6 is not so good you know
right uh but then he simply has the
winning uh Queen
H5 and then Rook
F6 this you missed when you exactly so
it looks like he's not threatening much
other than other than Queen H6 made but
in fact yeah well Queen H6 made but then
also Rook H6 so yeah so that's what I
miss I mean it's for some reason I
believed that Queen E6 was forced in
order to open the bishop but it's not
the best move the queen H5 is pressure
and then I think it just totally lost no
this is of course okay maybe I shouldn't
take but it's still already just a it's
a bad bad situation I mean it was a
blunder but again maybe I thought it
okay I could just make any move you know
and then put the Knight but probably
it's always uh just better for white and
uh these pawns are just weak it's not it
looks like black has some you know
activity but objectively it's probably
never working you know well certainly
thank you for your graciousness one last
question we really need to put it in
context you played them two games now
you don't have to worry about this kid
anymore you get four games to play
against the normal players right now it
seems oh you've been around the chess
scene for a while is this as amazing as
anything you've
seen
um okay it's absolutely impressive of
course I could only remember carproof in
um Laris I think when he started six and
a half out of seven it was extremely
strong feeli as well but that was
different guys was not round
robin um so that's at the moment that's
the only we're going back 20 years to
find that that's 1994 okay I honestly St
Louis St Louis the Argentinian city of
St Louis when I play I do believe it was
weaker than you know this event so maybe
even weaker than
Laris uh because then we had well maybe
not weak but we had udith she was
extremely in very bad shape and then I
think cim janov he was then uh below
2700 So This is an average rating 2802
to start the tournament this is
absolutely strong so you're impressed by
this as well oh for sure yeah well thank
you so much vesselin we appreciate
you're spending some time with us
showing us your thoughts and uh good
luck playing the regular guys okay
vesselin toala former world champion
class act as usual guys thank thank you
Maurice what do you think are we ready
for a break or oh I think we're going to
get Fabio and then take a
break so what do you think how did end
up with the Carlson's game against Maxim
bash oh you want to take a look at no no
no no I'll bring up uh so they um Maxine
is actually should be pleased although
he uh again is suffering a pawn behind
at least in the position that they have
Black's King is no longer under those
mating threats that would have occurred
had there been a white Pawn on G5 and
also to his credit the pawn on H4
although it's not a big uh danger of of
going all the way and making a queen
white has Rook H7 check black has
improved his position but do you think
we can somehow get that c Pawn running
or maybe even oh definitely put pressure
on A7 at some point make it difficult to
protect that pawn oh well definitely
white is going to be seeking to play C4
C5 and probably trying to uh maybe nurse
its Advance with his own King but again
I mean from a position where I really
thought that Maxine was dead that he
wasn't going to be in the game Beyond 20
moves um he's been given chances to save
it I would just put it like that now we
are ready with our guest sinkfield cup
leader with a perfect six out of six and
his rating keeps raising 2830 now
apparently according to the live rating
list Fabiano kowana is with Maurice
Ashley Thanks Jen with Grandmaster
Fabiano fabulous Carana Fabiano uh I
know we've been asking you all kinds of
questions what I want to know is what
have you been eating we want to hear
what did you have for breakfast this
morning um eggs and bacon good old
American breakfast well congrat
congratulations on your game could you
have imagined that the game would go
like this I mean this was just a
demolition okay I got my position out
out of the opening again I prepared this
line so I was very comfortable and he
was clearly a bit rattled I mean which
is normal when when you're surprised
from the opening and playing against
someone who's just playing instantly and
has everything
analyzed um okay later he blundered his
position was already pretty unpleasant
but I think Knight C6 just loses on the
spot and I think what he missed was um
he probably thought he could go with his
King to G7 he did point that out yes and
after Queen H5 and Rook fit Rook F6 is
just over immediately and in the game it
was also over very bad how did it feel
to to play this move against an
attacking genius like vesselin topalo
this must have been a great moment uh
well you spent some time by the way I
guess you're allowed to spend time well
I mean I'm sacrificing to peace so I
have to to double check that I'm not
didn't miss something I I don't mean I
don't want to lose the game um I was
still worried after I played it that I
had missed something but the variation
seemed so
straightforward yeah in fact they were
and he didn't seem he could have played
Knight D4 and and kind of fought back a
he not really a fight but he you
mentioned that topalo he's a great
attacking player but sometimes on
defense he's a little uncertain and and
maybe just go because he didn't have to
go down that that easy he just fell
apart it's probably losing after Knight
D4 wants to play Bishop C4 um and he can
win the exchange but I think that uh I
mean with Queen C6 B3 Knight C2 but I
think even if he takes one of my Rooks
I'll just mate him at some point um but
yeah he probably could have put up more
resistance but in any case I think it's
already pretty much
lost people are comparing your
performance to the performance of giants
karpov back in in 94 is the the closest
one anyone can think of that's 20 years
ago you were two you don't even remember
that happening can you can you
contextualize being compared to to those
kind of EP epic performances um well in
terms of play I'm not even close to to
Caro he's still a decent player I
remember right just decent but okay I
mean his
performance yeah I I really didn't
expect that I could do anything like
this and yeah I guess it's one of the
well let's see how the last four games
go but so far it's yeah probably one of
the best
ever uh what how do you get your mind
right for the for the future games I
mean you could go
10 and0 no I don't think so I'm not even
thinking about that uh I just want to
play solidly the remaining games try not
to lose anything and just keep playing
normal
chess uh you're you're going to be
facing is it Vila gra tomorrow yeah um
expectations thoughts about that game um
okay I'm black so I mean okay when
you're
black from the start you're always uh
under a bit of pressure you have to for
equalize the game um and I'll just try
to to play normally um he maybe he's not
feeling at his best at the moment if he
if he loses today against Magnus um but
in any case he's still very dangerous
player and I have to to uh keep control
and try to to play a solid game
2830 you were just like 2802 28
something 2830 does that make any sense
uh it's unexpected um I'll try to keep
it in the future of course it's not easy
to keep a rating like that but um but
okay if I keep playing good chess then I
should be able to well keep playing good
chess decent chess uh the nicknames are
are continuing for you we appreciate uh
your play and it's a joy to watch your
games good luck in the rest of your
games thank you our leader first place
with a perfect 6 and0 score just an
amazing start we are watching watching
history in the making Fabiano Carana
with us uh we're not worthy yeah you're
right we're not worthy guys such a fun
game too really fun to watch and you
know a few rounds ago Fabiano when he
was just three he said he was playing
decently yes this round he mentioned
that he was playing normally and that he
would like to continue to play normally
and solidly yeah and you know there's
this uh there's this new fashion thing
called Normcore which is the idea that
you should just kind of dress really
under stated normal so bringing normal
back Fabiano Carana with six out of six
and we are going to take a quick break
and we'll be right back with more from
the 2014 sink field cup as we see
whether world champion Magnus Carlson
can grind another endgame win against
mvl
I'm Magnus Carlson and you're watching
the sinkfield Cup live here from St
Louis and we'll keep an eye on Magnus
Carlson's game against Maxine basier
lrav today whether he can squeeze out a
win there meanwhile U Maurice Ashley has
the answer to the puzzle with h cesen
call versus
Nakamura this is one of those finishes
that you remember forever the when we
saw this get published I remember
personally seeing it get published and I
just thought who is this kid so young
was was Nakamura when he played this
queen sacrifice I don't know if you guys
found this if you didn't know the answer
and you found it kudos to you you're on
the path to becoming a top 2700 player
this move is beautiful white has just
just played the move Bishop to F6 that
looks delicious he's attacking this
bishop twice he's discovering an attack
on the queen his Bishop's got this Rook
on lock down it looks like he's about to
wrap up the point against this upstart
kid except here comes a queen sacrifice
out of nowhere this sacrifice an
incredible move King takes and then the
beautiful move Bishop to C5 with check
and now this this Bishop hiding in
weight don't step to F1 cuz C3 is going
to happen and you're just going to get
ripped so white had to go up the board
and face the wrath of a harmonized black
Army King to G4 was played and now
Knight to E5 with cck and you can
already start feeling the heat for this
King he played King G5 it didn't matter
what he did at this point he tried to
play the most logical moves and wondered
maybe I'm okay here except suddenly Here
Comes This waiting move guarding this
Square threatening mate on 86 and
suddenly white has nothing to do because
his army is too far away so he had to
sacrifice this Rook for this Knight but
that brought this Rook into the game
Rook check and now after King to H4 a
beautiful retreating move taking over
for the Knight square the square that
the Knight had taken in the first place
and this one now three pieces ganging up
on the king and all these white forces
just spectators at the king is shredded
a fantastic finish by Nakamura showing
the kind of tactical skills that he has
and that's why he is now one of the
elite players on the planet
guys Beautiful Finish By hikaro and
today though he isn't given those
opportunity uh to show his tactical
flare as we've seen a very quiet game
and where he got outplayed and
still the game yeah let's take a look at
the position now because actual position
on the board looks like it's okay for
white now right so Black's just captured
a Pawn on
A2 and but we should be able to win one
of those back C6 or A7 exactly a move
like Queen
D7 um looking very uh attractive with
the idea of hitting as many pawns as you
can um and indeed Queen d was played and
leavon responded to it with King to G8
so guarding both against the queen E8
mating ideas and against just Queen
takes F7 exactly so King
G8 and this game looks appears to be
heading towards a draw right sure we can
take on C6 and then if green takes
C6 um and now I think it's just time to
make lft just to give our King a little
bit of a you might want and Jen in this
position to force Black's Knight to a
little bit more passive before capturing
just so that the Knight isn't actually
sitting out here uh but still this looks
uh it looks like it will be drawn right
because either player tries to harass
one of those pawns and the other player
will harass the other and there will be
that nice little balance uh going on in
the position still Queen and this
particular Queen and Bishop combination
I do see that there there there is some
dangers uh to Black's King and it
appears that uh White has the Sunny Side
I would say of an of a drawn position
now in our other key uh game that's
still going
on Magnus had entered this Bishops of
opposite color endgame position where he
was a pawn ahead but Maxine has done
very well to get play for himself by
moving as H Pawn as we see now this move
Bishop A5 was a very important move
white was dreaming that he would get the
opportunity of playing F five to F6
followed by Rook on E7 to E8 check and
mate the pawn on F6 guarding the G7
Square the bishop on e4 guarding the H7
Square so this key move Bishop A5 in
order to be able to play Bishop takes C3
check followed by Bishop takes F6 uh
provoke Magnus to play C4 and now the
move H3 and um well I think you think
Max doing a good job of holding the
balance here well he's getting very very
close to saving the position um at this
moment so I think
Magnus uh is feeling that uh somewhere
earlier he had slipped and he's leted
his opponent off the hook sure now
Black's going to try to play play H2 and
the threat of Rook takes C4 is in the
position so precisely I think white
might be compelled to try to prevent
that play a move like F6 even well F6
like we say uh just walks into this
bishop check and we get to grab this
Pawn I was thinking that maybe at least
we can get our our Rook behind the pawn
then that's what I was thinking to stop
it from running up the board right I was
thinking that if anything Rook E6 you
get a position maybe like this and you
hope that you can somehow break the
blockade it does look like Magnus has
played a couple of moves and he played
your move Rook to E6 yeah but
unfortunately I do think that this move
H2 oh hold on we can we can slip in a
check but that's not uh sorry so what
play the problem is that Rook that the
bishop on e4 is hanging so you don't
have time to play Rook H6 and Rook takes
H2 meanwhile Rook takes E4 is Poss is
obviously the threat after H2 so um
Maxim on move right now and we're
expecting this move H2 and just to
finish this line if we do see this uh
what black is wanting to do is bringing
his King very quickly over here so that
he can toss away his pawn and take this
Pawn so first he has to stop E7 yeah
Bishop B4 or Bishop E8
yeah okay let's say Bishop B4 because it
gives you fewer options right there's no
C5 at all right but on the other hand
how Magnus has got to calculate if he's
in time in a position like this whether
or not he'll but I think that this is
just going to Save the Day for Maxine if
he can get his King to
C7 uh I don't think he has any problems
hold in the draw those Bishops of
opposite color it's going to be very
hard for Magnus to win the dark
squares um uh overcome the dark Square
blockade I mean to say in any in any
case Maxine has no choice I think he
simply has to go for this line and hope
that it's enough for him to hold the
game that's right and it looks like he
has just played a move so we're
expecting
H2 um Maurice some
thoughts well that game is proceeding a
bit of pace so I'd like to make this
short the moment we saw here was this
move H5 a very interesting move maybe
necessary move by mvl and after takes
Rook takes attacking the bishop across
the board and also attacking this Pawn
so Bishop takes Pawn takes and now
Bishop back to E4 still well played by
Magnus but it was here after Rook to H1
that the computers are criticizing
magnus's next move the move F4 they
thought that the best move here was
actually to play the move C4 or maybe
even Rook H7 with this idea keeping an
edge The Rook could always go here and
be prepared to stop this Pawn from going
any further and this bishop will come in
at the right moment just as long as the
bishop is secure the insecurity of this
bishop or security of this bishop was
the main thing to worry about in this
position instead Magnus played the move
F4 and that caused some problems for him
after this rank was controlled now C3 as
the king can make no further progress
and now H4 F5 and now Rook to E3 and we
see that Bishop now unable to maintain
its security the best move they give
they already say in the computer saying
that this move uh this position is sort
of equal that the bishop has to kind of
float along this diagonal but it gets
away from this idea of The Rook being
able to get behind the pass Pawn
critical to have your Rooks behind pass
pawns can't get to H7 anymore so this
move Magnus played Rook to E6 and
already the injes are saying Believe It
or Not Black's better I don't get that
that seems a bit crazy in this position
Bishop A5 yes was played C4 and the move
H3 and Rook to E6 was played by
Magnus and the move H2 was played and
now Bishop to D5 and now the engines are
coming around and saying okay you're
right it's equal and so this position
should be a draw coasting towards that
result now and with a draw in this game
that would mean that CaRu would be up
three full points with four rounds to go
that reminds us of golf when a when a
guy is up a bunch of bunch of holes
bunch of points with holes to go uh with
a few holes to go and you just unless he
Bogies every single hole you ain't going
to catch him and it looks even worse
here even if Carana lost like we could
imagine him losing two games out of the
next four he's still still has the
tournament in his pocket so it looks
like this result is making it closer and
closer to that mathematical certainty
certainly it's a betting certainty that
Fab Fabiano Carana is going to win this
tournament and the real question is Will
he win with a perfect score he said he
doesn't think it's going to happen but
if these players keep trying to hunt him
down every single game and make him play
we might see something special here at
the singfield cup guys put your life
savings on it
just kidding we don't advocate for that
kind of thing here Malcolm Payne uh kind
of clarifying what he said earlier sure
um he said that this is the greatest
tournament result of all time or it's
shaping up to be um not to be confused
with fiser 20 streak in match play which
included match play I'm thinking so
making a little bit of a distinction
there well there's been some really
great performances outstanding I still
remember this tournament that Gary
Kasparov one it was the GMA tournament
in Bel for he had some unbelievably
Wicked score and again larus 9411 out of
13 by anat karpov was simply uh
unbelievable uh during the break uh I
was actually chitchatting with Rex Rex
singfield and Rex said that uh prior to
the tournament beginning the probability
of Karana especially Karana cuz he
wasn't the highest rate of turn player
in the field the possibility of him
winning six in a row was 3% and Tony
Rich has has created a little
probability table uh before 3% three uh
the the 3% you mean less than that right
no the idea that uh that um Fabiana
could have started with a 60 result
before the tournament I would think it
was like 97% against that happening I
mean think it' be even less than 3% I
thought so too 3% sounded like a lot 3%
sounds more like four or five but no 3%
well according to uh the probabilities
that that um that uh Tony had calculated
regardless whether it's 3% or a third of
percent it's pretty marvelous pretty
remarkable and uh speaking of a heading
towards a draw uh Maxine did play this
move Bishop to d8 just defending the P
defending against the pawn advance I
actually I had actually considered
however briefly the move King uh
G7 E7 Queen but in this particular
position uh Queen by white there's no
reason that Maxine would allow uh two
queens to appear on the Queens to appear
on the board so he did play this uh
correct move I want to say bishop d8 and
there's no way that uh Magnus can
prevent the king from coming to F6 and
then the pawn on H2 is traded for the
pawn on E6 and the resulting A2
C4 extra Pawn unfortunately is not going
to be enough for Magnus to win I think
we're off by a digit really I just was
thinking about it I think they might be
off by a decimal point because think
about that that if it was only if it was
3% that would mean that this result
happens three out of 100 SN field cups I
don't think so I think maybe three out
of a thousand sounds more right I think
that sounds I think I think they meant
maybe a third of a percent we we'll
check on that a third of a percent
sounds sounds more correct than 3% to me
doesn't it imagine this tournament
happens 1,000 times how many times does
Fabiano Carana start with 60 right I
think three out of a thousand sounds
more in the ballpark than three out of
100 three that's not that that's not
even that low I mean Poker we we play
poker
3% 3% is Big that Happ you're all in
right okay
gotcha all right I don't know about that
but I just say we can get lucky 3% all
right let's just see what uh what we
have left uh the players are in a queen
and pawn end game between um and we have
a draw in the uh we have a result in in
the Carlson vashir lra game okay the
players uh played very quickly let's see
how we got here when we had left it the
Rooks had been traded and then um Magnus
recognizing the impossibility of winning
the game played very quickly got to this
position and offered a draw as um
there's no way for him to break uh the
blockade that black has set up Magnus is
leading fast he does not look happy one
interesting stat that probably won't
surprise those of you who've been
watching this with an Eagle Eye Fabiano
caran is now closer to number one than
to number three for the first time well
he
behind Aran and now he's actually closer
to Magnus than he is to aonan that's the
idea such a a gap between himself and
leavon wow and that's a tweet from Top
40 chess so thank you to that and by the
way just for our amateur players in the
audience just to explain why would why
would uh Magnus world champion Magnus
two pawns up offer a draw to anybody
well what Magnus understood is that for
example after Bishop King King King you
can get this what what's going to
happen is black is just waiting and
there is no way for white to win with
the pawns so he just goes back and forth
with a king just Waits and
that's why a draw was offered so classic
blockade we SE we seen Bishops of
opposite color in the middle game in the
toolup game where he won right so in
this case the exact opposite it's the
end game and that's why they called him
drawsh right and also another uh
blockade that you can't break is if he
goes Bishop C5 King here and you just
keep maintain your Bishop on this
diagonal there's no way for white to
push his pawns through Black's position
now meanwhile Maurice Ashley looks
excited about something what's up uh you
must have read my mind or something
because I was just thinking about this
great start by Fabiano Carana just just
such an epic start to a tournament and
the idea that he started in third place
on the rating list and he was that close
to to I mean it was just mathematic was
a point or two but that he's now put
such a spread that he's up at 2830 I
mean when you think about that that's
insane you only gain 10 points and
you're jumping up and down in the
streets that you gain 10 points at that
level and to have gained 30 almost 30
rating points that's obscene that's
absolutely obscene and he's separated
himself from the rest of the pack and
we're seeing two the two top players in
the world right now one that he's
already defeated the number one player I
can't wait to see that matchup happen
again what do you think Magnus is
thinking when he plays Fabiano that next
one I mean everybody in the tournament
now is going to have to I mean what are
they thinking get a draw They're all
playing for second place I mean that's
the fact they're playing for second
place which is a nice $70,000 I believe
so they're playing for a second they
can't they have to make sure they don't
lose to this guy I mean he's just
stomping on everyone's heads so will
they go for a draw with white pieces or
will somebody say I'm I'm taking up the
gauntlet I want to be the one that stops
this run at history and holds him back
show that he's actually mortal just a
really amazing situation it it
percolates with so many possibilities
I'm completely enjoying myself here a
bit too much here at the singfield cup
just awesome and I I'll just say this
there are two types of Chess tournaments
one where the players play to the very
end we love these last round everybody's
tied and they're going for the marbles
or one where a person is showing that he
just dominates nobody can touch him and
he keeps winning most importantly not
just drawing to finish the tournament
but keeps on winning and we're seeing
that one now and it's just as exciting
guys and let's take a look at the world
rankings updated as we Marvel at
Fabiano's incredible performance here
we've got Magnus Carlson
2862 number two in the world now 2830
and yeah look at that gap between number
three now Lana Ronan
2793 VN toov
2781 Karo Nakamura at
2773 and MBL at
2767 wow so great uh yeah just great to
get updated on that as well from Malcolm
uh Payne's tweet about you know great
great tournament
performances
um okay not not not necessarily elite
elite events but certainly eye-catching
eye popping I
recall Sophia Polgar remember sop and a
half out of nine that was in Italy
exactly speaking of Italians instantly
you obviously it connected with you too
that was just an incredible TP tpr I
thought it was over 3,000 I could be
mistaken then there was a Alexander
morvich also I think it was a Lloyd's
Bank tournament I'm not 100% sure but he
went something like n and a half out of
10 and just an absolutely phenomenal
performance ran away completely defying
the math and we do have some uh some
Math wizzes typing in that just telling
us what the odds are that the odds of
something like that happening obviously
are not going to be totally precise
because of the momentum effect and
whatnot but yes that I think it was a
third of a percent not so off by one
decimal point not really a big deal
right but still absolutely extraordinary
and we have world champion Magnus
Carlson with grahas Maurice Ashley to
talk about today's
game thanks J the number one player in
the world Magnus Carlson with us Magnus
it looked like you had some chances in
this game but they seem to slip away
after a couple of imprecise moves yeah I
I mean I I missed uh a number of things
I think um this end game should be
technically winning for for me but then
yeah he defended quite well and I just
kept on missing missing stuff but I I
think it must be it must be very close
to winning at least do you feel slightly
off form this tournament the way you've
been playing the last four rounds or so
I thought yesterday I mean not yesterday
but the game with theonion was okay uh
in general I played three good games
with black and three terrible ones with
white and I don't know why so a draw now
puts you at three points behind Fabiano
I mean this guy's playing out of his
mind what did you think about his game
today I thought too played horribly
today
um um I mean U still you got to win it
so he did well so he's got six points
you've got three he's plus plus good God
knows what what uh what do you think
about the rest of the tournament is
there anyone who's going to catch him no
no I mean there's not I mean I'm
three-point behind three points behind
and I'm the closest so naturally he's
not going to be caught but I don't know
I'll do my best in the rest of the games
including um the one against uh him but
I mean after today I've I lost the very
very little hope I had left of winning
the tournament I was saying it looks
like the other players are playing for
second place now does that matter to you
that you're you're going for second
place I I don't care about second place
uh I I just want um
you
know finish with some good games and get
a positive results uh result that um
um yeah that's what I need to do and if
that's enough for second or third or
whatever
that's that we'll see uh the individual
game against him you mentioned I was
saying there four games left people
might want to bring him back down to
earth you think that the players are
going to have the attitude play him to
the fullest and try to defeat him I I
don't
know um I think uh yes I mean tomorrow I
wouldn't bet on Fabiano winning another
game uh but then again he's won three
blacks so far so you you mean tomorrow's
game you would better winning tomorrow's
game tomorrow's game yeah and because
because he's I mean te is probably going
to play pretty solidly with white but
then again I might be
wrong just one last question you seem
down right now you seem dejected is is
uh it's just um no I had such a good
position
today uh this game really could have
turned not the tournament around but my
own tournament around and and I screwed
up so that's
uh um that's why I'm in a bit of a fou
mood now oh all right well uh enjoy the
rest of the evening we hope your mood
picks up we look forward to to seeing
your great play and good luck in the
rest of the tournament thank you world
number one Magnus Carlson after a draw
and uh we'll see what he can do to get
his tournament back on track
guys it was Magnus seemed anxious to
escape
there a smile though I know uh one of
the things I admire very much about
Magnus by the way is it's an incredible
objectivity not only at the chess board
but just in terms of keeping everything
under perspective
speaking of smiles uh Lana Ronan and
hiar Nakamura analyzing their game which
of course was a draw that steered that
direction for a little while the queen
ending uh three versus three easy draw
for these top Grand Masters even though
at the very end uh Hikaru had a smidgeon
of an edge just because of his better
structure but dead drawn and so tomorrow
we're going to see some interesting
matchups uh what are the matchups we're
going to see well we've got Carlson
versus Nakamura and we've got Maxim
vasher lra against kowana that's the key
game right Carana is going to be black
and vesselin toala against
leonan wonderful always always great
great games and great matches in every
round uh but mvl and two Sicilians today
right mvl can he do it could expected
that and we are GNA take a look at the
standings um six out of six for Fabiano
carolana right still awesome
that's what they say in Missouri by the
way
awesome and we're picking up th those
standings and yeah six out of six uh
just one of the most incredible
performances ever and not over yet
tomorrow black pieces against NBL game
will be exciting Anything could happen
without without a ding it's almost
impossible to calculate fabiana's
tournament performance rating it's way
up there maybe as high as
3600 that without a draw it's impossible
to calculate in the stratosphere that's
right Carlson in second place so you
know he was in the basement a couple
rounds before so picking up and as he
mentioned in the interview needs to dig
deeper with white pieces Maxim Bashir
lra two and a half Vel TOA two and a
half um Ty for last hiar Nakamura and
laavan Ron and they split the point
today right so both of them are going to
be looking to just increase their rating
and try to fight for those top prizes
second place is
$75,000 Magnus says that doesn't affect
him he's more interested in the world
rankings and playing some good chess
true true he's not interested in second
he's interested in proving himself every
time he steps on the
board he he wants to prove himself that
not just world champion but number one
so lots to play here still at the
sinkfield Cup Final thought from
grandmas Maurice Ashley well looking at
those standings it's pretty remarkable
it looks as though one player is playing
by himself and the others are in a group
together with a heated battle for second
place we could almost get excited about
that race if it mattered so much you saw
Magnus say second place Pasha I'm not
really interested but I'm sure the other
players are thinking well you don't be
interested but 75g sounds kind of nice
to me so that will be some real play
still going on they've basically
basically acquiesced to the fact that
Fabiano is going to win the tournament
and they don't want to be victims to him
you heard this statement which I think
is kind of cure statement by Magnus that
vashi lrav is going to play solidly he's
not going to try too hard so he doesn't
think that that Fabiano is going to have
a win tomorrow well mvl is going to have
to say something about that because
certainly he's looking to seek revenge
for his loss against Fabiano so I think
that that game will be interesting will
be exciting and as will the other games
as these players fight it out in the
final four rounds of the singfield cup
guys and my final thought is a great qup
by Hans kamak Hans kamak was the Arbiter
in the US Championship that Bobby Fisher
won 110 at the closing ceremony Hans
kamak came to Grandmaster Larry Evans
and congratulated him on the first place
then he turned to Bobby Fischer and
congratulated him on his exhibition what
we are witnessing is an exhibition here
by Fabiana Karana I was wondering when
that story was going to come up and I
feel like this was a perfect time so if
you want to continue watching history in
the making here at the singfield cup the
strongest tournament ever and one of the
best performances of all time by Fabiano
Carana then tune in tomorrow for round
seven action 150 Central Standard Time
and 250 on the East
Coast